[Music]
your new single
don't be sad tell us about that one that
one was actually
really crazy to release because i wrote
that like around two years ago
everything you shouldn't say to a sad
person and everything you shouldn't say
to an anxious person like
don't be
just don't anxious is there anything
that is off limits when it comes to your
lyrics and your music
basically just write about everything
that i've experienced up till this point
and emotions that kind of go through my
head as a high schooler
[Music]
your song you broke me first had over
100
million streams in general your music
has over 450
million streams what does it feel that
your music what's it feel like to have
your music connecting with so many
people it's really crazy
you know i just never ever thought it
would
that seems weird to think but like i i
trained my whole life as a dancer and
you know
writing songs was just something i loved
to do even when i started my youtube
channel
back in 2017 it was like the first time
i'd ever released like songs
that i'd personally written myself um
and i put it out on the internet and
was like super vulnerable it was
basically my diary online
and you just don't like people have an
interest in your life i'm just super
grateful
that people are really liking my songs
and connecting with it